quoi moi erreur de destinataire non moi
c'est pas ça qui m'arrive et moi un jour
je voulais raconter
j'étais chez un copain ouais en fait et
ils partent parfum et part en boîte et
il nous laisse chez lui avec deux autres
copains qu'est ce qu'on fait et toute la
soirée nous a saoulé parce qu'il avait
une nouvelle installation sonore
ouf braquo d'histoire et est donc qu'est
ce qu'on a fait on a mis un film porno
et on anime est à fond dans l'immeuble
mais quand je vous dis à fond ça veut
dire que mes genre vraiment un truc de
ouf
et qu'est ce qu'on a fait on est parti
de chez lui et j'ai fermé la porte
1 en partant et on a laissé à fond le
dos et en partant pour ferme la porte
j'oublie que j'ai laissé mon portable
olala possible de le récupérer
là le mec est en boîte ils voyent à son
concierge qui l'appelle monsieur qu'est
ce qui se passe
il peut vous avez eu un malaise il ya
les flics qui sont allés narre les
voisins ont appelé les flics ils
arrivent chez lui il croyait qu'ils
s'étaient ils croyaient qu'ils avaient
eu un malaise en regardant un film porno
donc là on est devant tous les voisins
tout ça fout tant d'eau à fond il rentre
chez lui mais ce truc et lightroom mon
portable qu'est-ce qui fait ils envoient
tout le monde je vous dis patron de m6
thomas valentin nicolas de tavernot
vincent bolloré tout le monde tout le
monde alexia tout le monde stéphane oui
ça tous les animateurs tous à tout le
monde
il envoie j'étais c'était il était genre
4 heures du matin et pour moi j'ai très
envie de te bouffe et le luxe je n'ai
pas eu que des reçus
à
et c'est vrai que voilà et pas souvent
les personnes qu'on croit qu'il croit
nicolas de tavernot le lendemain à
l'arrivée anglo sa secrétaire vous manu
l'aimé rendez-vous des journées jean
chose à faire est ce que matt et mathieu
question parce qu'on m'a fait matthieu
louppe oui ils envoyaient des grands
patrons à toi y'a rcn j'ai envie de me
tenir debout c'est là dans cette
émission a l'impression dont on a besoin
d'un temps ferrari on a quelqu'un en
estafette la façade sur eux s'ils
voulaient record